for months I've been telling you that
this relationship between right-wing
FoxNews radio host and television hosts
Sean Hannity and Donald Trump is very
very bad news for America and we know
that sometimes Sean Hannity is the last
person Donald Trump speaks to before
going to bed Hannity sort of tucking
Trump in proverbially speaking
colloquially speaking we know that
Hannity has become just a blindly loyal
supporter of Donald Trump's pushing just
any old Trump friendly narrative on his
TV and radio show that that comes to
mind or that someone suggests to him no
matter how outrageous it is and we know
that Trump is impressed with these
strongman types in politics like Putin
and erawan but we also know that he
seems to be equally impressed with the
strongman types like a powerful media
figure such as sean hannity so this
relationship between Hannity and Trump
had disaster written all over it from
day one and we've now learned that
Donald Trump recently ordered the
declassification of sensitive documents
because Sean Hannity among others told
him that he should do it
there have been Trump's about there have
been reports about how Trump recently
told the Justice Department to go ahead
and declassify materials related to the
Moller investigation which is absurd for
a few reasons including that Trump is
part of what's being investigated and
he's the last guy that should be saying
what should or shouldn't be declassified
related to that investigation Trump
wanted FISA warrant applications
released related to Carter page who we
recently interviewed he wanted FBI
reports about interviews with Justice
Department officials Declassified he
wanted messages sent by James Comey
about the Russia investigation
Declassified really a ridiculous request
and a terrible idea especially since it
could expose intelligence sources and
methods that are being used by the FBI
so Trump was interfering with an ongoing
investigation by merely requesting the
release of these documents he was
possibly endangering American security
interests again he was jeopardizing once
again relationships with allies who
might see this and say wait a second why
are we going to share in
information with the United States if
Donald Trump might willy-nilly asked for
that information to be Declassified at
any time that's what we knew so far so
Trump then gets interviewed this week by
the hill and he said you know I actually
haven't even looked at those documents
but people I respect like Sean Hannity
and cuckoo for cocoa puffs judge Jeanine
Pirro said I should have these documents
Declassified and released so I did it
but I didn't even look at the documents
myself here's a transcript from the
interview that he had with buck Sexton
where buck Sexton says have you reviewed
the memos yourself what do you expect
them to show if so and then Donald Trump
responds and there's an ellipses here
because there was some other stuff in
between these these two sentences I want
to be very clear about that Trump says I
have not reviewed them I have been asked
by many people in Congress as you know
to release them I have watched
commentators that I respect
begging the President of the United
States to release them I have been asked
by so many people that I respect please
the great Lou Dobbs the great Sean
Hannity the wonderful great Jeanine
Pirro it would be bad enough if Donald
Trump was personally dictating policy
but instead the people he listens to our
dictating policy and one of those people
is Sean Hannity another one of those
people appears to be wacky judge Jeanine
Pirro and there are White House aides
who are now referring to Hannity as the
unofficial chief of staff because of the
influence that he seems to have over
Donald Trump I want you to think just
for one second let's all do this little
exercise sit back and imagine this for a
second it's announced that Barack Obama
has ordered the declassification of
documents that could expose the
identities of 10 CIA agents working
covertly for example confounding
decision why why would you release
something like that and then a few days
later George Stephanopoulos interviews
Barack Obama and Obama says honestly I
don't even know what the point of it was
I did it
because Anderson Cooper told me that I
should really release these documents
just to pick someone can you imagine the
outrage 24/7 on right-wing media on
Hannity on Rush Limbaugh on the entire
entire thing if Donald if Barack Obama
had done that and the double standard
here where Trump says listen people I
respect judge Janine Hannity they said
released the documents no I didn't look
at them because they told me to release
him I don't even know what it's all
about Obama would be destroyed if he had
done something similar yeah but we don't
get that sense of outrage when Trump
does it because we're so used to it
we're so desensitized to it and I feel
like in a way Trump wanted to declassify
these documents all along but he knew
that it would look bad in the public eye
if he did this because after all the
investigations into him right but does
it look better to say Hannity told me to
do it he's trying to say other people
encouraged me to do this you know people
like Congress people and media figures
like Jeanine Pirro and Sean Hannity I
wouldn't be at all surprised if Hannity
gets pulled further into the Moller
probe because of his degree of contact
with Trump he's provided a platform for
Trump to push his lies in the apologia
about Russia he's tied directly to
Donald Trump's indicted former personal
lawyer Michael Cohen it would not be
even an iota surprising to me if sean
hannity ends up being a bigger figure of
interest in this entire fiasco send me
your thoughts what is going on here I am
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I want to
hear from you we'll take a quick break
and be back after this today's program
was made possible in part by Blink
esteem / Pakman I love bling cast it's
the really perfect app for anybody who
likes politics and learning and if
you're watching or listening to the
David Pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
says is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can
absorb the most important valuable
information from books in just 15
minutes maybe on your way to work maybe
on your way to the gym maybe cooking
vegan recipes at home whatever is your
thing and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for just about five bucks a
month you can go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n to sign up